c'est comme il ya quelque chose quand
même non moi je crois que c'est mon
chiot ses cheveux châtains foncés
c'est vrai nom châtain clair ah oui aux
yeux bleus oui ce n'est pas méchant
c'est un feu vert dont ils sont clairs
oui oui
gibbs signe particulier une grande
bouche domicile quartier latin c'est
vrai c'est ça oui pour les admirateurs
rue
avenches et maisons de campagne pas
encore la mienne alors alors du mois 10
privée
la situation de famille degré
d'instruction établissements scolaires
langues français anglais danois suédois
italiens italien cause il a fait de la
danse elle s'est bougé de ses marchés
c'est très important c'est que bien
quelque chose quand même non
[Musique]